the army only entered the amarula lodge
in palmer long after those trapped here
had fled
survivors told us of a terrifying three
days under fire
surrounded by militants and left to fend
for themselves
among them were these two south africans
where's on the left and his older
brother adrian
[Music]
this footage filmed by wes on his phone
shows them taking cover in the hotel
where nearly 200 people had taken refuge
his brother is lying in front of his
father greg in the czech shirt
now back home in johannesburg wes said
the shooting
and mortar firing was constant you know
the gunfire just didn't stop the mortars
i mean you're talking about hundreds of
mortars
going off like probably
40 50 in an hour
but despite the fighting getting closer
and closer the brothers are constantly
supporting each other
love you bro
at this stage only small helicopters
operated by the private security company
dag appeared to be mounting
any rescue people were getting more and
more desperate
but after airlifting more than 20 people
from the amarilla
dag promised to return for more
inside the lodge wares and the others
are waiting to go
keeping as quiet as possible and joking
about what they can take with them
as the gunfire continued they sorted
themselves into small groups and had
their bags ready to go
and then they heard the helicopters
leaving we said to them we're sitting
ducks
we've got nothing to protect ourselves
we need confirmation asap using
satellite phones
they repeatedly appealed for help from
those in pember and on the
fuji peninsula nearby where the big gas
project is
wearing flak jackets left behind by aid
agencies
and with no weapons at all they come up
with a plan to break out of the lodge
side gate
and retrieve a weapon they think is in
the parked car outside
they don't know how many insurgents are
lying in weight
but they know they're surrounded adrian
in the blue flak jacket
volunteers to do the running and
searching
what you doing adrian come
adrian come
it takes three runs before they come
back with a single gun
with no help apparently coming they
began packing themselves into the
vehicles left at the lodge
the aim was to head out in a convoy
adrian would drive one car
it's gonna be the driver of your life
bro
within minutes they'd been ambushed
several drivers and vehicles were hit
and careered off the road
the brothers vehicle was amongst those
who kept going only to be ambushed a
second time
he just started shouting that he's hit
he's hit
and that his leg is off and he can't
drive
someone needs to take over everyone was
shouting at him just keep driving as far
as you can
he's like i'm trying a kilometer after
that
um he was you know just say i can't i'm
going guys i'm going
i was holding his shoulder over the
bullet went
trying to stop the blood and i was just
pumping out
ah started to drop and i was just
shouting back at them
to to put the other the other doses
inside
the the bullet the the gunshot wounds
and um was he still talking
no he had stopped talking about that
time and i was just shouting
that i love him and that i look after
his family
and that i'm so sorry i'm so sorry that
this has happened to
they hid in the forest until the next
day before dag helicopters rescued them
with wares insisting they take his
brother's body with them
this is the short shirt i was wearing
this is his blood
this is all of his blood that was on us
from
myanmar trying to save his life
people forget that we did
everything for everybody and it felt
like nobody was doing anything for us
and my brother paid the ultimate price
they just abandoned us didn't help us
no i'm left with this
adrian leaves behind a wife and three
young children
the amarillo lodge where he took refuge
was ransacked
with villagers saying 12 foreigners
who'd stayed behind
were beheaded here they buried them
beneath this tree
the militants tore through palmer
killing an unknown number
and thousands are still missing alex
crawford
sky news in mozambique